Hey youtubers it's Charlie. So the BBC
just announced info on when they're
gonna post the next trailer for the
50th Anniversary episode.
As well as TWO new Doctor Who Mini
Episodes. I've also got some really big
announcements to make about special
Doctor Who videos that I'm making with
BBC
and Nerdist for the 50th Anniversary
episode so be sure to SUBSCRIBE to get
all the info!
So first of let's start of the new trailer
that's going to be posting November 15th.
So I know a lot of you weren't able to make
it to Comic Con, so
most people have not seen any actual
footage from the 50th Anniversary
episode.
So this new trailer that they're going
to be posting on the 15th will actually
have footage from the 50th Anniversary
episode.
So here's the details, the clip is going to
air on November 15th at 7:30 p.m.
on BBC1 during a special Children In
Need 2013 Special.
Don't worry if you don't get the BBC or
you live in another country. They'll be
posting it online on their YouTube
channel right after
just like they did with the last clip.
So now let's talk about the Mini Episodes
So both of these Mini Episodes will be
appearing on the 50th Anniversary
DVD. They won't be appearing online so
you have to buy the DVD to get them.
The first one is called "The Night Of The
Doctor". It will pick up
right after the events of the 50th
Anniversary episode and it will star
Matt Smith
and David Tennant. It'll be about 7
minutes long so it'll be a fully
self-contained small episode. The second Mini Episode is called "The Last Day"
and currently we really don't know
anything about who's going to be in it,
other than Matt Smith,
or what it's going to be about. It's only
about 4 minutes long so it might not
be
a full Mini Episodes just like "The Night Of The Doctor". Don't worry if you can't
buy them or you don't get to see them
I'll be doing a full breakdown and
review of those Mini Episodes once they
start selling them on December 2nd.
I'll be posting my review the actual
50th Anniversary episode on the 23rd
right after the episode airs.
So you'll be able to see that much much
sooner. But here's details on all the special
things that I've been invited to do with
Nerdist
in the BBC for the actual 50th
Anniversary Episode. So first things first,
we will be doing a very special live
stream with Nerdist
and the BBC on the actual day. It'll
start in the hours leading up to the
50th Anniversary episode
on the 23rd. Don't worry I'll be posting a lot
more information about the actual livestream
when we get closer.
Second, the BBC has invited me to make a
bunch of special Doctor Who videos
in the weeks leading up to the 50th
Anniversary episode, so
the actual 17th November 17th is the
beginning of "Doctor Who Week" on YouTube
Think of it as like a special Doctor Who
Takeover of all of Youtube.
I'll be making a very special video that
week that will post on the BBC's Doctor
Who channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get that. In the
next couple weeks I'll be doing about
8 special Doctor Who videos leading up
to the 50th Anniversary Episode.
Just to help distinguish them from all
the other videos I do for the other
shows, I'll just be adding a special Doctor
Who bug at the bottom here that you'll
be able to see.
So if you have any questions about the
Doctor Who videos that I'm doing or any
questions
about the 50th Anniversary Episode,
the Mini Episodes or the Christmas
Special or even Series 8,
please leave them in the comments and
we'll discussify. Seriously guys pie here's this is
going to be such an amazing month, Doctor
Who is taking over the world.
So please SUBSCRIBE and help join me in
celebrating Doctor Who.
seriously we're going right from the
50th Anniversary Episode to
month long celebration of
the beginning of Peter Capaldi's reign
on Doctor Who and the end of Matt Smith's
reign. It's going to be so amazing.
In the meantime you can click here to
get all my videos for the 50th
Anniversary Episode.
And you can click here to get all my other
Doctor Who videos. Seriously it's going to be
amazing guys. Thank you so much for watching,
High Fives! See you tomorrow!